A few months back, my brother Ian showed
me an amusing Tumblr post. A link is in
the description if you want to read the
whole thing, but long story short, this
post lays out a format called Ulipo
Dragon Scotsman.
In ODS, participants play with a 99-card
singleton deck that is led by a
commissar, a legendary creature which
can be cast at any time. Okay, it's EDH,
but without any E's in the names of
cards. Naturally, I had to do something
with this information, which brings us
to today. Last week, I instructed the
people in my Discord server to submit a
deck with no E's, and to also include an
approximately 100-word written work to
accompany it, also without E's. Was that
part because getting almost 400
submissions on my last deck building
challenge just about killed me?
A snail never tells. However, among the
much more manageable 180 submissions
that these somewhat irritating
requirements produced were some really
delightful submissions. And in this
video, I want to tell you about some of
them and how they managed the daunting
task of excluding the most common
character in the English alphabet. I'll
also be including a number of honorable
mentions on my website, since there were
some really great submissions, both in
terms of deck building and writing
quality.
A major struggle for people with this
challenge was finding decks and
archetypes that aren't too hindered by a
lack of E's. Not being able to build
decks with E's eliminates roughly 83% of
all Magic cards. So, if you have six
cards that do a particular thing, on
average, all but one of them will be
eliminated. However, some types of cards
had shockingly few of their options
eliminated. For one, polymorph cards.
Only around half of all polymorph cards
were eliminated, leaving a respectable
five left for any red-blue decks to
enjoy, which was taken advantage of by a
neat Yasova deck that was submitted.
Another survivor was the card Rat
Colony, which allowed people to easily
fill out a large portion of their deck.
And this was utilized by a particular
Gerrard deck. A third deck that was
relatively unhindered was Ratadrabik
Nazgûl combo, a deck style submitted by
several people. The one I'm going to be
highlighting here is a Delightfully
2000s deck, Nells Arcanum Dagsson
Station deck. Let's start with the poem.
Four stations in total, any will do.
Possibility without limit, actions until
all is ruin. You must grind to summon,
and salvaging must follow blasting.
Wanting won't stop sorrow, for
annihilation will find a way.
Artifacts for good? What a laugh. You
know what is coming. All you do to fight
will only bring it to pass.
Only a tool, your thoughts void against
my monarchy.
Not a man, only a commissar. Only my
way. Only war.
Arcanum Dagsson is a spicy commander
from Coldsnap, and he's one that has the
potential to be quite powerful in
modern-day unrestricted EDH.
Four mana for a creature that can
sacrifice an artifact creature to find a
non-creature artifact every turn is
quite potent. And the non-creature
artifacts we have available to search
for in the year of our Lord 2025 are
quite horrifying compared to what
existed back when Arcanum Dagsson was
printed in 2006.
However, what do the top-tier tutoring
targets like Darksteel Forge, Portal to
Phyrexia, and God-Pharaoh's Statue all
have in common?
E's, of course. So, naturally, any
Arcanum Dagsson enjoyers had to get a
bit more creative, which brings me to
the tutoring targets of choice for this
deck: stations. There were four cards
printed in Fifth Dawn with station in
the name, and it just so happens that
none of them have E's.
Two of them you may know as classic
combo pieces, Blasting Station and
Grinding Station, whereas Summoning
Station and Salvaging Station are
somewhat less popular cards that only
hipster YouTubers play.
However, when the four of these are in
play at the same time, all of their
respective abilities and untap clauses
merge together to form an infinite combo
with each other, so long as a low-cost
artifact for Salvaging Station is in the
graveyard.
The two high-cost stations are activated
to create permanents, which untaps the
low-cost stations, and then those two
are activated to sacrifice the
permanents and inflict harm on
opponents, which untaps the high-cost
stations. Rinse and repeat until
opponents are dead. So, the heart of
this deck is these four artifacts and a
commander who can find them. But what
supports that? Well, first, artifact
creatures. This is the resource that
Arcanum needs to create his stations, so
naturally, there are 19 of them. These
cards span a variety of purposes, with
the most common being to help the deck
ramp. Some of them are a bit filler, but
with a commander like Arcanum Dagsson,
that's not really a problem.
The other key thing this deck has is
protection. Arcanum is a scary
commander, so to keep him alive, this
deck is packing nine counterspells and
five other pieces of protection.
Filling out the rest of the deck is a
handful of removal spells, as well as a
variety of other artifact-related cards.
There are a handful of cards that seem
here specifically to synergize with
certain stations, a number of one-cost
non-creature artifacts to allow
Salvaging Station to come online, and
there are likewise a couple cards that
can let artifacts untap. Trading Post
also lightly synergizes with a couple
different stations, yet another possible
machine that can be cobbled together.
All of this has a very retro energy
about it, and I enjoy that. Moving
along, something else you may note about
this no E's format is that it excludes a
basic land, forests.
This challenge did have a somewhat
below-average number of green-containing
decks in general, but there were a
surprising number of people who opted to
build a mono-green deck. There are
something like 11 lands without E's that
both produce green and are legal in a
mono-green commander deck, and pairing
those with a modest number of
green-producing mana rocks can get you
up to a simple count that's an
aggressive mulligan policy away from
being adequate, I suppose.
Adding on an extra color makes the
situation a bit better. It seems like
non-basic lands tend to have fewer E's
than other card types, so there are a
surprising number of options within
two-color decks. That brings me to a
green deck that I want to highlight:
Shuckles Momir Vig BioVisionary deck.
There was actually another Momir Vig
BioVisionary deck. Shout-out to the
person who made that one, but this is
the one I'm opting to feature. Let's
start out with the story.
Lost and lacking will, Momir looks
through his list of organisms. "Nothing
is worth his scrutiny," Momir complains.
Finally, his scanning finds a grand form
without fault, BioVisionary.
Thinking hard, bold but rational
philosophy turns logic through airtight
analysis. Satisfactory strands of
thought align into his magnum opus:
Simic Assistant Tutor, a Cryptid
Zoologist, a Quandrix Cultivator, an
Amped Entomologist, a Bookworm. All
paths find BioVisionary.
Momir looks for mana through dirt,
rocks, and things part both. His supply
is found. A cunning trick finds its way
into his mind. Bouncing his assistants,
a Portal of Sanctuary, a Shard of
Crystal, and an Umbilicus fulfill his
fantasy. With BioVisionary on board,
many cards copy it. Organisms such as
Mockingbird, artifacts such as Soul
Foundry, and surprising magic such as
Sakashima's Will allow Momir to join in,
too. Four mirrors from a primordial
first, a smiling Momir claims victory.
That story laid out a lot of what the
deck is doing, but let's do a brief
rundown. Momir Vig is a commander with
two abilities attached. Casting green
creature spells lets you tutor up
creatures to the top of your library,
and casting blue creature spells lets
you draw the top card of your library.
So, casting blue-green spells puts cards
directly into your hand in classic
original Ravnica fashion.
BioVisionary is a card that wins you the
game if you have at least four copies of
it in play on your end step. In a
singleton format like EDH, this means
that some form of copying is generally
required to make it work as a win con,
and naturally, this deck has a fair
amount of that. 12 cards exist to copy
it in some form or other, though these
span a wide range of things. You've got
the basic copy plan, which will take a
bit of effort. You've got the stronger,
though non-tutorable plan of using a
card like Sakashima's Will on a wide
board. And you've got riskier plans such
as exiling BioVisionary under Soul
Foundry and hoping to be able to
activate it four times. As for finding
each of these components, the deck
features nine Simic creatures for
purposes of tutoring up clones, as well
as a number of other green creatures.
There are also cards like Crystal
Shard and Umbilicus, which bounce
creatures to be recast, and which can
also let the deck repeat ETBs on top of
that. Outside of that, this deck
features a good amount of ramp, which
seems like a good idea for a couple
reasons. For one, Momir Vig is a
five-mana commander with a concerning
effect, so that's basically a seven- or
nine-mana commander if you think about
it. Outside of commander tax, Momir Vig
also feeds the deck card advantage at a
healthy clip. So, naturally, it makes
sense to make sure to have a way of
spending that. In terms of green
symbols, this deck contains 15 amongst
its lands and two amongst its colorless
ramp, for a total of 17 symbols, which
certainly isn't great, but can be made
workable enough with a somewhat
aggressive mulligan policy.
This deck certainly represents a fun
navigation of this challenge's tricky
requirement. A number of people went for
more conceptual decks. No E's is a very
specific format requirement, and asking
for some sort of writing submission
likewise put people into a creative
zone. One cool choice was a Kirk deck,
with the deck builder pointing out that
Kirk was canonically originally named
Kerric, and his choice to remove the E
from his name meshes nicely with the
nature of this challenge. Another fun
choice was an Underworld Cookbook in a
rule zeroed sideboard and a wish in the
main board, with the idea being that
Asmoranomardicadaistinaculdacar
lost her cookbook and is wishing for its
return. There were also not one, not
two, but three X decks submitted. That's
the Unstable card that puts itself into
your opponent's hand.
The deck I'll be highlighting is an Iron
Man deck that also chooses to engage in
just a bit of silver-bordered action.
Let's start with the story.
"It's missing. How?"
Tony hasn't got an inkling. With a total
of 62 4K cams running constantly
throughout this wing, saving and backing
up 2 TB worth of visual data to his main
SSD array hourly, no burglar of any
amount of skill could slip through such
vanishingly slim cracks. Still, Jarvis
had scrupulously dug through it all at
his insisting, only to turn up nothing.
And what was Tony anticipating to find
anyway? It's not a physical thing that's
missing. No, this was a villain's doing,
not your bog standard cat burglar. But
who? Doom? No, no motivation.
Loki?
Now that would fit, but
it's difficult to sort out his thoughts
without such a vital symbol. And Tony
Stark's a man of action anyway. Sitting
around ruminating isn't his strong suit.
As his armor's hydraulics hissed into
motion, Iron Man sighs and shrugs.
Just got to go out and find it, huh?
Iron Man himself is a five-mana flying
beater who creates treasures and offers
a birthing pod sort of effect for
artifacts each turn. Should I have heard
that sort of effect as an Oswald effect?
A repurposing effect?
Anyway, turns artifacts into other
artifacts. The silver border card this
deck features is Now I Know My ABCs, a
card that wins you the game on your
upkeep if you control permanence with
all 26 letters of the alphabet in their
names. Iron Man is actually a great
choice to go with this for a couple
reasons. For one, treasures. That's an
E.
Secondly, it allows the deck to go
hunting for some of the less common
letters out there that might be attached
to artifacts.
Naturally, this deck has a number of
artifacts with less common characters.
Tamiyo's Journal, Blazing Torch,
Drivers' Familiar, Acquisition Octopus,
and so on. There's even Spy Kit, an
equipment that gives a creature the
names of all legendary creatures, which
certainly simplifies the game plan a bit
as long as you can keep the creature in
play until your upkeep. Even outside the
artifacts, there's a lot of variety.
We've got Accumulox here for that lovely
French Vanilla Mirrodin game play, as
well as Grass Lak and Zorn.
The core of this deck is Now I Know My
ABCs, but this deck has a good number of
options to pivot into a more
conventional artifact beatdown sort of
plan if needed. Sharding Sphinx and a
handful of other flyers make for a solid
plan alongside combat damage to player
effects.
All of this and more is explained in the
deck's 700-word primer, also including
no E's. I have to respect the effort on
display here. I briefly toyed with the
idea of writing this script E-less, but
quickly abandoned that idea when it
became clear how difficult long-form
writing without E's is, particularly
when it comes to navigating around
common words I might normally use, like
commander or deck.
So far I've chosen to feature decks that
have a neat premise or which flaunt
restrictions in some sort of creative
way. However, the final deck I'm going
to show off in this video is one with a
decidedly more focused goal. Mirrorwing
Tiamat deck. I'll let the description
explain the basics. This is a cutthroat
Odes list born for playing at maximal
optimization within its format's bounds.
Fixing for mana of all colors was rough,
but Food Chain and a full armory of
supporting cards at my disposal was too
good to pass up. With a fairly low
amount of stack disruption, this list
wants to pull off its combo as quickly
as it can.
You know, it's occurring to me that all
four decks I'm showcasing feature a
commander that tutors for tools that
help with some sort of unusual combo.
You should definitely blame 33 Alk for
that. He helped me in selecting the top
decks here.
Anyway, let's talk about the commander.
Tiamat is a five-color dragon that costs
seven mana and tutors for five dragons
when he enters.
You might think that this means that the
deck is a dragon deck, and it does have
two dragons, but that's where it decides
to call it good. This is because in the
context of the deck, Tiamat's role is
simple. He's just the way the deck turns
infinite mana into a win.
I say infinite mana because this is a
Food Chain combo deck. Food Chain is a
card that allows a player to exile a
creature to add its mana value plus one
in mana that can only be spent on
creatures.
This combos with Mist Hollow Griffin, a
four-mana creature that can be cast from
exile, creating infinite mana that can
be spent on creature spells. Once
infinite mana is obtained, Tiamat is
then cast, searching for Dragon Lord
Dromoka and Hoarding Broodlord. Dromoka
is here for protection for the rest of
the combo, shutting off opposing spells
and thereby protecting the two critical
creatures that will follow from creature
removal.
Hoarding Broodlord is a dragon that
gives all players spells cast from exile
convoke, and on ETB tutors up a card to
exile that can be cast. That card is
most likely to be Joyful Stormsculptor,
a card that deals one damage to each
opponent whenever a convoke spell is
cast. Once each of these is on the
field, the deck then goes back to loop
Mist Hollow Griffin with Food Chain a
bunch more times, since the Griffin now
has convoke when being cast from exile
and thus deals one damage to each
opponent per cast, eventually burning
them down. Because Food Chain exiles as
the cost on the ability, and because the
deck plays Dromoka before the other
critical creatures, almost all creature
removal actually can't interact with
this combo, which is pretty wild. The
two things that can interact with it are
enchantment removal to destroy Food
Chain and counterspells to nail key
spells. And the deck naturally runs
eight counterspells to deal with that.
It also runs nine cards to slow down
opposing game plans, which makes sense
to buy just a little bit of time for the
deck to set up. Outside of this, the
rest of the deck's cards focus on
pushing it to the point at which it can
combo off. We've got effectively 35
lands, 14 sources of mana acceleration,
11 tutors, and 13 draw spells to let the
deck find and play Mist Hollow Griffin
and Food Chain.
A secondary benefit of Tiamat is that
the deck has ample options for what to
use for these. While losing E's
restricts the card pool a lot, having
five colors allows basically all of
these to still be respectable choices.
It also allows the deck to have less
trouble with the mana base than it might
otherwise. A full eight original dual
lands don't contain E, and though there
are only two untapped fetches available,
another four tapped fetches make this a
bit less problematic. Overall, this is a
very fun deck to showcase the limits of
the no E format. So those were the decks
I wanted to highlight, but I'll briefly
mention a handful more that will be in
the honorable mentions. Pillow Lake
submitted a sort of build-your-own
slicer deck. It's a Godo deck that wants
to find Assault Suit, and they included
a very flavorful story to go with it.
Elusive Panda submitted a Gonti, Lord of
Luxury Inquisitor theft deck that
includes no green symbols whatsoever,
and which needs to use one of its other
theft cards to steal a source of green
mana from an opponent in order to cast
Gonti.
Finally, Salmon submitted a high-powered
Glorg Doomsday deck that's pretty cool.
There were actually several Doomsday
decks submitted. You can check out all
those decks at the link to my website
down in the description. Hopefully you
enjoyed seeing these decks, and if you
hated every minute of it, you can move
along with your day in peace knowing
that this is probably the last one of
these I'll be doing for at least a few
months. With that said, thanks for
watching, and thanks to Archidekt for
supporting the channel. One of my
favorite things about the site is the
front and center Scryfall-style search
box that can allow quick and effortless
filtering of cards by Oracle text,
color, or mana value.
I'll link to all my decks in the
description if you want to check them
out and see how many times the word
attack or search shows up in them.
I also like to thank my patrons, some of
whom are on screen now.
It's always great to know that I can
make what I want and am somewhat
shielded from the whims of the algorithm
by the kind people who directly support
me. If you want to support the channel,
a link to my Patreon is in the
description.